[Musique]
[Rires]
le
[Musique]
paris qui passe c'est le pari qu'ont cas
ce que l'on détruit sous nos yeux sans
que nous en prenions conscience car nous
sommes devenus des gens pressés des gens
distrait les flâneurs les badauds qui
prenait le temps de regarder ça n'existe
plus
dans quelques années pour se souvenir
il faudra feuilleter des albums de
photos grâce à des hommes comme robert
doisneau sont heureusement fixer des
images que notre seule mémoire ne
parviendrait pas à garder intact
[Musique]
non
et
[Musique]
m
écoutez voir la rue de paris c'est
attendre quelques fois deux heures même
place deux heures
et dans le fond la vision n'est pas très
rapide on pige pas comment dit la rue
tout de suite il faut vraiment beaucoup
de temps pour voir une rue et petit à
petit les choses deviennent évidentes
est ce qu'on ramène par la photographie
n'est pas du tout objectif c'est très
subjectif
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
au début de ce siècle paris était encore
une ville provinciale
si les vieilles rues étaient étroites
les revers des maisons ouvraient leurs
fenêtres sur des courts intérieurs clair
et calme que la spéculation a effacé
sous le fallacieux prétexte d'élargir
les rues pour l'été envie de presse est
imprimeur lithographe ont connu ce pari
là et le feront revivre sans
attendrissement inactive
moi je suis un très beau quartier du
parc montsouris un quartier qui était
déjà très coté aux points de mu peintre
peinture il fuji day enfin tous les jeux
primés tous sur la loi une douzaine et
je suis donc natif et j'ai vécu ce jeune
homme de 25 ans et ensuite je me suis
expatrié
c'est à dire mais je suis monteur baisse
est expatrié parce qu'il est monté dans
le 18e mais le 18e c'est un métier c'est
un quartier de peintres aussi à ont il
ya eu picasso il ya eu même des grands
écrivains et tout il a rien à trouver
drôle au 14e
en réalité nous sommes dans 10e ici et
c'est une feinte de belleville par le
fait est que quand je suis arrivé ici je
me suis retrouvé un peu dépaysé mois
descendant de la butte
j'ai trouvé une grande cour avec des
vieilles locataires qui regardait
derrière leurs cordes qui a été l'intrus
qui venait dans le pays dans le pays
c'est le cas de le dire parce que leurs
courses et leur domaine elles si vive
asie sont les enfants sont partis pour
aller dans des maisons plus confortable
évidemment ici comme confort n'y en a
pas alors les enfants sont partis mais
l'ailier qui sont restés avec un état
d'esprit tout à fait de village
parce que pour moi
les vieux quartiers de paris cédait même
tous les quartiers de paris c'était des
villages j'ai connu le square
saint-pierre où il n'y avait pas encore
ces grands escaliers où c'est encore des
palissades on pouvait se glisser et bien
là il y avait des coquelicots qui
poussait avec des herbes assez rare mais
enfin ces deux ponts nous c'était la
campagne mais c'étaient des
fortifications du fait que des au parc
montsouris
c'était ont préféré m'en aller se
promener sur les blues
l'europe ce n'est pas pour nous c'était
pour les merles et à godets y avait eu
ou il ya dans le site universitaire il y
avait les fortifications avec des nids
d'abeilles dedans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
paris a toujours été une capitale
culturelle et artistique mondialement
apprécier les touristes y viennent
nombreux et le développement du tourisme
international permet dit on au peuple de
se mieux connaître à condition de savoir
rester soi même mais la place du tertre
n'est plus elle-même ni toulouse lautrec
né bruant ni francis carco ni utrillo ni
tant d'autres ne reconnaîtrait la butte
montmartre fauvisme le cubisme
etait-il l'expression prophétique de
cette curieuse superpositions de
couleurs et de formes qui plonge paris
dans sa grisaille actuelle la luminosité
du suffixe l'étudiant était bien
[Musique]
le bien-être matériel est devenu un bien
nécessaire mais elle ça bien suffisant
donc on vivait avec moins de confort
peut-être que maintenant on envie j'ai
mieux alors on était plus heureux mieux
c'est à lui qu'on ne le connaissent pas
ce confort on n'en souffrait pas et puis
il ya une chose c'est que ont le désir
était moins important que maintenant on
était heureux beaucoup moins de choses
on était heureux de se revoir en droit
comme un défaut au petit café et bien
souvent dans les dents les cours dans
les escaliers
on savait ce que ce que l'un faisait ce
que l'autre pense et toute la petite
famille comme vient de bannir pour
l'être c'étaient des choses qui étaient
plus humaine bon ce n'était plus humain
à ce moment là que je crois qu'on l'ait
maintenant on n'avait pas de problèmes
d'énergie sinon d'énergie personnel oui
à dépenser son énergie on l'avait parce
que moi je me rappelle est descendu
travailler à pied devant marc je
travaillais à l'opéra je descendais
facilement le matin un pied puis c'était
un régal
parce que d'abord il n'y avait pas
toutes les voitures les embouteillages
et où l'on pouvait descendre
c'était une partie de plaisir moi
j'estime que c'est ce que je me dis
toujours aux jeunes gens vous vivez dans
un petit cube vous êtes chez vous vous
êtes dans votre petite cage vous prenez
l'ascenseur c'est une autre cage vous
mettez dans votre voiture c'est encore
une autre cage il n'y a aucun contact
jeudi dans le temps prenez le métro on
avait des attouchements qu'il n'est pas
toujours agréable mais enfin il y avait
vraiment des contacts
[Musique]
nous trouvons ici au 212 de la rue saint
maur dans le 10e arrondissement
c'est je crois que c'est une des anciens
cour de napoléon pour l'ancien bâtiment
les anciens écuries ici même s'il faut
mourir
c'est très rare de voir un homme de
votre âge eux être encore artisans je
pense quand même jamais encore quelques
heures
non magique dans le quartier beaucoup de
jeunes partaient oui c'est vrai c'est
exact c'est d'abandonner plus ou moins
de gens qui n'aiment plus haut
d'artisanat vous êtes ici vous depuis
enfin votre famille depuis plusieurs
générations
oui depuis plusieurs générations allez
on était au 212 rue saint amand nous
sommes depuis dix-sept ou dix-huit
anglophone et avant nous étions passage
puis vers enfin 5 600 mètres d'ici
wisner le pape alimentaire à toute
famille à continent
la tâche des gardes je vous les
donnerais par la suite il reste encore
des chaînes njawe m
[Musique]
m
et
vous regardez les photos que vous avez
fait au cours des dernières années est
ce que vous trouvez que ça change très
vite formidablement formidablement ces
photos c'est comme un membre un monde de
tout à fait ancien mais ce n'est pas de
voitures dans les rues
maintenant il ya un chapelet
d'automobiles qui se touchent un jour il
y aura une soudure total et on sera
forcé de découper au chalumeau
mais les gens allaient au mieux quand on
faisait une photo les gens étaient au
milieu de la rue ah oui ça s'est su
prouver enfin sur les images maintenant
c'est possible c'est un autre aspect de
la ville
[Musique]
dans le quartier de la république un
porche débouchés aussi sur une cour
intérieure avant la révolution
cette course se trouvaient dans
l'enceinte d'un couvent des jacobins que
napoléon 1er transforma en caserne
la caserne de crussol dont le cirque
d'hiver était le manège monsieur gare
aux artisans sculpteurs il ya toujours
son atelier mais mon père était venu au
7 rue oberkampf g a trouvé ses papiers
en 1885 ya beaucoup de brassage de
population dans ce coin quantités
énormes de population de trois salles au
fur et à mesure des années les et les
migrants qui sont venus que ce soit des
des français ou des étrangers ça a été
des des couches c'est pareil par exemple
mon grand père c'était loire active du y
avait plus de travail il était mariniers
et il est un prêt sur de longs il est
venu ici à paris parce que mon père
venait d'avoir son serre des véhicules
et de primaire et naturellement pour
apprendre un métier
et au fur et à mesure sûrement d'autres
couches au mieux mais les différentes
couches sociales qui sont venus ici sont
le reflet de l'immigration pour venir
sur paris et montre il ya des et
franchir les échelons
ici la caserne très sale était une
première et donc voilà peut-être
pourquoi les rues change parce qu'il ya
moins de mélange
on a l'impression que tout est tendu
vers un classement rigoureux des gens
les gens qui ont pu mélanger et le
mélange c'est très vivant
quand vous avez il vous vient une idée
une inspiration ce parce que vous
recevez une différentes sollicitations
de toutes parts la rue était est et
était drôle parce qu'elle était très
mélangées maintenant non on est plus
mélangé on est classé mon atelier et en
plus et en plus braves à paris et avait
en plus haut point de paris avec les
jeux d'ailleurs après la réaction
c'est à dire au point à quelques
dizaines de mètres
le parquet de paris ici nous sommes à la
hauteur à peu près de défaut cds anciens
procès de la bastille et lier la rue à
blue est peut-être le fossé dans lequel
venait l'eau de la seine jusqu'à paris
d'ailleurs à la place de la république
quand ils ont fait les travaux qui le
métro ça doit être en 31 30 ou 31 ou 29
pour aller à la porte dorée et avait
l'exposition coloniale et ils ont trouvé
des squelettes de vache
c'était mal c'est d'henri iv qui fit
construire la place des vosges centre du
quartier à la mode au xviie siècle
mais même en matière d'urbanisme les
modes ne dure pas paris n'a jamais cessé
de se transformer cependant quand au
xviiie siècle on offrira louis case de
lui consacrer une place il écarte à tous
les projets qui proposait de démolir des
maisons déjà existantes ait choisi un
emplacement nous construit au bout du
jardin des tuileries
l'actuelle place de la concorde on ne
fait plus tant de manières au 20e siècle
le baron haussmann à donner l'exemple au
19e on achève son oeuvre
[Musique]
abada grill c'est tout à fait différent
belleville en train de changer changer
complètement complètement de ce qu'il a
été et de ce qu'il est moi j'ai connu
bellevue ma grand mère demeurait au 126
rue de belleville
j'avais un frère de lait tous les deux
on faisait les chats de gouttière à
courir sous les tuer et quand je vois
encore maintenant il ya un poissonnier
quand je vois sa crosse devant dans la
ville d'ailleurs il y avait une chose
qui nous choquer qui nous plaisait qui
nous empêche de dormir
il y avait eu fini tu les as tu monte et
les rails étaient déplacés juste devant
chez la grand-mère on n'entendait pas en
temps en temps en temps des rookie qui
martelaient et de choses et il s'arrête
à l'église de belleville ce qui nous
plaisait deux autres étaient gamins
c'est comme monter au dessus de payer
jamais envoyé le calice des sondés les
tickets ou alors parce qu'à ce moment là
donnez pas piquer leur saveur est un
troll la plateforme qui chahutent ans il
fallait d'abord des acrobates montagne
au dessus et à chaque fois qu'il monte
personne qui faisait sonner du contrat
puis ça cet été compté pour ce conteur
qui enregistrait alors il y avait
entente sur la grand mère il y avait à
la friteuse aller voir de lui c'était il
y avait un fritz est éteint calabre et
de la calabre et les manger des maçons
italiens ou encore des migrants qui
était venu déjà qu'ils fréquentaient
belleville sur des tables en marbre
ils vendaient de la morue frites et puis
des verlan s'adonnaient c'était
épouvantable
un devoir lui loire et alors ma mère me
disait tout le temps un truc très
amusant et faut pas manger de ça parce
que c'est fait avec de la graisse de
mort avec ça parce que c'était du cheval
c'était des traces choix et la friture
reste bloquée
[Musique]
je
le
[Musique]
e
comment pourrais je dire ça comment on
pourrait dire ça oui
dans le fond pour moi la rue qui
m'amusait bien c'est bien chez nous on
voyait retraités avec son petit chien
blanc un arabe qui vendait des tapis un
gosse qui traverse eric 1 1 enfin là il
y avait une vie extérieure qui était
il était bon enfant et les gens
n'avaient pas rende dans la rue ce qui
change maintenant on a l'impression que
les gens ne veulent plus ne paraître que
ce qu ils sont sales et donc dans les
restaurants d'employés on chuchote dans
les stands ouvriers on parle de ce très
fort d j'ai l'impression que la ruche
shot maintenant et puis il y avait une
chose que le jeu puis si encore il ya à
peu près une vingtaine d'années les
marchands de fauteuils ambulants ils
faisaient des c'était des roms
généralement des [ __ ] qui vendait
des photos bilan il y avait une chanson
c'est moi le marchand fauteuil d'enfants
c'est moi qui les fais c'est moi qui les
vend c'est ma femme qui voulait que la
galette
je vends des fauteuils rembourrés c'est
tout la femme avait initiée et puis
l'annoncé qu'il revendait 3 franck sens
où mme maintenant je parle de ça il ya
une vingtaine d'années quand j'étais
gamin c'était très courant il y avait
toute une vie
[Musique]
m
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous allez être expulsés de votre maison
d'elvis aux halles heureusement qu'est
ce que vous voulez c'est un petit
cottage ces gens du golfe tout essayé en
vain
est ce que si on vous proposait de
reloger à la place dans un des
appartements dans les moeurs le faut
pour toi pour cette gentille que font
courir les clapiers à lapin ça me paraît
pas beaucoup quand on touche je suis
pour toutes fins pratiques des grandeurs
énorme je touche le plafond je fais
doivent arrêter je touche le plafond et
leur pouvoir pour voir comment de
luminosité et puis être temps c'est
comme ça c'était semestre ' on sait même
plus vivre je me demande comment aps les
gens renoncent à des hommes et dieu sait
que j'en ai visité à temps pour un
empire je ne voudrais pas qu'elle
comprenne nord faut ouvrir la fenêtre
pour mettre son paletot
écoutez je ressens je veux pas dans
l'opinion sait pas si c'est beau c'est
vilain c'est gigantesque c'est colossal
alors comme devant un géant on apprendra
de l'opinion sans ses rivaux écrabouille
je n'ose pas dire ce que j'en pense
enfin je ne sais pas bien encore c'était
très joli c'était ce sont des prouesses
techniques sa valeur mais je me sens pas
très à l'aise le xiiie arrondissement
est un des grands champs d'expérience de
l' architecture moderne à paris mais là
non plus et tours n'ont pas poussé sur
des terrains vagues
m
monsieur nous sommes ici sur un terrain
qui a beaucoup changé
c'était quoi avant c'était la maison à
la maison c'était plus qu'une maison
ah oui j'étais l'usiné on appelait
d'entendre l'appel la maison pas vous
avez travaillé à l'usiné poire en 50 ans
qu'est ce que vous faisiez comme
tourneur professionnel qu'est ce que ça
vous a fait quand vous avez vu démolir
les vieilles maisons est monté six mois
oui j c'est malheureux quand même un
nouveau jeu de fish le corps dans une
maison neuve et avec l'argent qu'on veut
qu'on m'a payé ça c'est fatal vous avez
eu la même impression madame oui croyez
pas ça possible parce que j'avais
toujours entendu dire que le treizième
était creux ok je ne pouvais rien y
construire
vous êtes mieux logé que vous n'étiez
oui sûrement
oui oui j'avais deux pièces et une
cuisine il y avait et l'ouganda cité
mais pas de chauffe eau paris chauffage
central
j'allais chercher le charbon avec quatre
étages à des 100 délicate à monter oui
mais ce que vous connaissez les gens qui
sont arrivés non il ya des gens que l'on
connaît oui dans dans le hlm mais on n'a
pas beaucoup ensemble pour toi là
pourquoi pas s'il ya des juges et des
grandes langues
l'église était dans le monument le plus
haut les guides qui hélas oui me demande
pürro ici oui c'est la fille de monsieur
point qui était marraine de quoi les
villes des cloches
la gloire de dieu n'est plus au plus
haut des cieux et les hommes de bonne
volonté ne savent plus très bien où
trouver la paix
[Musique]
oui
c'est rigolo cette idée de géométrie des
des cubes genre je crois que les gens en
ont tant besoin donc de lumière autant
besoin de quoi qu'ils n'en sont tus
faire maintenant alors que c'est si elle
est dans ses ateliers civil épousé
quasiment parnasse et ses actualités
plein de recoins la verrière fui un
petit peu évidemment le confort
s'améliore mais la recherche du confort
ça ne mène pas obligatoirement au
bonheur
[Musique]
non
paris change de plus en plus vite non
seulement parce que l'on construit ce
qui est normal mais surtout parce qu'on
démolit ce qu'on devrait préserver de
l'usure du temps
cette cour des miracles par exemple les
goûts les besoins les aspirations des
nouvelles générations ne sont plus les
mêmes dit on ce qui est certain c'est
que la sacro-sainte automobile autorise
tous les vandalisme
[Musique]
quand on entre chez les commerçants
n'importe où vous demande toujours si
vous habitez à l'accomplir a donc c'est
un endroit où il ya surtout pas mal
d'artistes or je pense est un peu qu'ils
avaient subissent les gauguin douanier
rousseau a commencé d'ailleurs à peindre
ici je crois c'est resté combien de
temps encore ici à sepang juste deux
trois ans peut-être les plus je pense
il ya déjà eu des personnes qui ont été
relogés oui mais une première fournée
une dernière ils sont partis dans des
ateliers qui ont été faits dans une
neuvième étage entre le 9ème 10ème on a
démoli des des plafonds non la garder
les fenêtres de l'immeuble parce que les
miens n'est pas la vraie lumière
d'ateliers ils ont eu beaucoup de mal
ils ont été très déprimés pendant
plusieurs mois ils revenaient tous les
jours ici les enfants revenant
s'accrocher aux poutres et que vous
l'écris partir ils sont deux ils étaient
d ici les enfants oui et nous disait je
suis né là je veux pas repartir je suis
là chez moi et on pouvait pas les
racheter
comment accepter vous l'idée de partir
d'ici c'est difficilement parce que
normalement
mal de retrouver cette ambiance et pour
travailler on a tout de même besoin
d'une certaine ambiance une certaine
atmosphère montparnasse a été très
sacrifiés oui je crois que cette année
et quartier qui a été le plus apprécié
j'ai l'impression qu'en ce moment les
artistes les expédier un petit peu au
milieu on n'a plus tellement fiq
d'artistes
par quoi va-t-on remplacer cette grande
maison à cette grande famille par une
route on va faire l'art dit albert saint
jacques taris qui rejoindra par éthique
de la rue du château je prends la maison
en deux
l'idéal cette perfection que l'esprit
imagine sans pouvoir y atteindre
complètement chacun ne cherche plus ou
moins intensément mais dans ces projets
les plus ambitieux il y a toujours au
fond de l'homme un petit coin de jardin
qui sommeille un petit coin à sa mesure
à l'échelle humaine une chose qu'on peut
que don peut embrasser soit comme ça oui
c'est une chose qu'on possède parce que
on pourrait dire mon escalier mme accord
pour ne pas dire mon ascenseur du 29ème
état je crois que ça c'est inhumain
c'est bien la tour bienséant de la grèce
puis 42 14 heures jean le sergent qui
seront eux-mêmes décomposé en 14 à
première chambre
le réseau tels que quatorze arrière
chaud par l'autre sol jusqu'au 9e le
niveau inclus ensuite les entrées
reprend du 10e niveau au 18e niveau
c'est-à-dire pour un ensemble ils à la
sporthalle des propos des ans par lettre
a et b pour un total de 104 heures deux
morts ensuite la deuxième batterie le 16
rue archambaud d composé également de la
différente
cesa acsb du 19e niveau 28 et le niveau
pour le 16 à et du val de vienne niveau
30 e tienne pour le csb est un non sens
datant d'avant le mental
non
[Musique]
et
ce sont pour les troglodytes du monde
moderne que ces ouvriers casqués termine
d'un instrument sans âme des orbes de
ciment armé
on ne sait pas encore à quel amour à
quel délice ses ordres s'associeront
beaucoup de nouveaux venus habitent déjà
certaines tours ils ont un certain
niveau de vie sur la rue de flandre
monsieur de lille et sa mère s'habitue à
leur nouveau magasin reconstruit une
vingtaine de mètres en retrait de
l'ancien qui appartenait à leur famille
depuis une centaine d'années
eh bien depuis 1867 la création de notre
affaire et puis même la fondation enfin
de l'immeuble même l'animent avait été
créée à cette époque la maman pattie en
eh bien c'était gelé
photo jg en photo ici oui c'est lui qui
a fondé le magasin mais il n'avait pas
du tout la vocation commerciale et c'est
plutôt sa femme qui a vraiment fonder le
magasin c'était une excellente
commerçante et c'est vraiment et c'est
elle qui avait été très très en avance
sur son temps oui c'est ça qui était une
femme très décidée qui a vraiment pris
en main la faire et qu'il l'a fait
prospérer
elle n'a pas eu d'enfants elle n'a pas
eu d'enfants elle a ici une magasin elle
son frère monsieur de l'idole et son
frère c'était qui il ya c'était mon
grand père que j'ai là sur la photo
justement enfin y aller pas dater mais
enfin que la situer à peu près en 1900
puisque mon père est là aussi à côté de
lui il est assis là il a une dizaine
d'années à peu près
alors comme il est de 90 je crois pas
pas 90 donc la photo doit être le poids
de 1900 le basket à droite c'est qui ah
bah là c'est le vendeur alors c'est
l'ont d'ailleurs qui était là oui mais
les dames qui sont aux fenêtres
alors là c'est les grands mères alors
qu'ils sont là haut yalla yalla
grand-mère et l'arrière grand mère c'est
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut beaucoup de coeur et de respect
pour toucher à la structure d'une ville
pour ne pas défigurer son vieux visage
en lui insufflant une jeune vie toujours
renouvelé toujours plus envahissante
robert doisneau ne se lasse pas de
photographier les derniers îlots les
derniers témoins d'un pari qui disparaît
paris hier appartenait à un monde
différent du nôtre dont elle était la
reine paris aujourd'hui est une autre
ville habitée par d'autres habitants
qu'est ce que le quartier représenté à
cette époque là qu'est ce qu'il a fait
dans le quartier j'avais beaucoup
d'ouvriers évidemment c'était un
quartier ouvrier
oui puis avec les artisans beaucoup
d'artisans il y avait bail avec la ville
est évidemment qui à ce moment là était
importante aussi alors il y avait
beaucoup au magasin forcément parce qu
on avait même une spécialité de la
boucherie des vêtements pour boucher
vous savez il tarde oublie blanc lourd
aussi mais pour seront les environs de
boucher et velours et floor d'amiante ou
des pantalons 2008 art les pantalons
taille haute et acier les gaziers là qui
étaient sur le terrain il a d'abord les
basques entendait tout le matin il
fallait tout tendre dehors tout les
blues tous les prix étaient affichés et
tout c'était vraiment l'état l'âge
vraiment tout à fait on m'a dit qu'il
avait des chevaux aussi dans le quartier
avant de oui oui horrible il y avait à
l'époque un anneau oui pour attacher les
chevaux justement et vous-même enfants
vous avez connu le tailleur à we will
tailleur qui était au bout du magasin
sur le comptoir assis là je me souviens
assis en tailleur tout à fait normale au
bout
oui ça c'était un souvenir d'enfance
tout à fait aux yeux
et vous vivez toujours au dessus du
magasin oui c'est ça oui ça change pas
beaucoup finalement d'être dans un
appartement neuf passes ça change quand
même oui oui forcément
enfin remarquer on on serait resté dans
l'ancien on n'était quand même pas mal
logés on aurait pu faire des
transformations qu'on n'a pas pu faire
parce qu'on dit toujours on va être
démoli on va être démolie puis ça
n'arrivait pas été attaché au quartier
parce qu'il y est née de naissance
intentions wii wii fit même polyclinique
pas venir ici
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que les
quartiers rénovés mais vider de leurs
vies ne viennent pas des quartiers
s'arrête ennuyé mais savait ennuyeux
alors pour animer ces quartiers dont on
a enlevé la sève il ya des troupes de
jeunes qui veulent animer la rue en
faisant des spectacles théâtraux dans la
rue ils sont plein de bonne volonté mais
je crois que c'est tapé à côté dans le
temps enfin c'est rigolo on fait moins
et un quartier et puis on lui fait une
transfusion de jeunesse cette tentative
c'est vraiment désespéré maintenant le
manque que les gens se rassemblent
souvent tour respectueusement d'un
garçon de très bonne famille qui
crachote que c'est drôle
il a bien du mérite c'est rigolo
[Musique]
il n'ya pas que ceux qui l'ont vécue
pour regretter le pari qu'ils devaient
être toujours en panne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
messieurs dans cette maison qu'on est en
train de démolir vous lisiez n'ya pas
longtemps
oui dix jours après vous revenez souvent
d'abord depuis dix jours non je me tords
ça vous fait mal au coeur est ce qu'il y
avait dans cette maison il y avait une
petite cour intérieure avec des arbres
il y avait des ateliers d'artistes
[Musique]
une très belle maison elle date du
milieu du 19e après c'était au début un
relais postiers et ensuite c était
habitée
enfin il ya des déserteurs qui vont
travailler et habiter notamment fernand
léger
je pense rodin
et parce que c'était un des rares
ateliers dans paris
on pouvait sortir de très grosses pièces
et vous êtes ou maintenant je suis dans
le
il ne vit
dans un appartement ancien dans un
bâtiment moderne
nous aimons non mais je compte pas y
rester
d'ailleurs je cherchais
dans le même style quelle importance
vous donner à cette manière de vie voilà
c'est fait
c'est indispensable de conserver dans
paris des des endroits comme ça est
d'autant plus qu'on fait rien qui
ressemble
c'est désastreux
est-ce que ce qu'on fait actuellement
est à l'échelle humaine je ne pense pas
vraiment à l'échelle des voitures et de
l'arche en poupe est grossier
[Musique]
mon
à
quelques vieux monuments quelques
vieilles maisons quelques vieilles rues
bizarrement isolé dans un environnement
étranger désespérément neuf reste
désormais deux bouts il ne se passe pas
de semaine que ne soit démolie quelques
vestiges épargné qui gêne d'un
alignement ou encombre l'emplacement
d'une percée futur il n'y a plus grand
chose à protéger mais peut-être doit-on
croire pour se rassurer que la vie sera
quand même la plus forte
non
on
[Musique]
ça me fait penser à la gare de service
vous allez voir à la gare d'austerlitz à
l'arrivée des trains le matin tous les
oiseaux l'ip piaf qui sont installés
dans la toiture connaissent les horaires
des trains et plonge d'un seul coup sur
les pare-brise des comment s'appelle par
les locomotives maintenant les machines
électriques attirer les trains bon bien
les motrices
il plonge sur les motrices et ils
viennent ramasser les papillons les
moustiques et toutes les choses
succulentes que la vitesse a accumulé
pendant le voyage
donc voilà si l'ailette arrive à
s'adapter puisqu'il ya plus de crottin
ya quand même l'arrivée du train 8h47
eh bien les gleek gosses sorti les gens
mon arrivée à s'adapter et à attendrir
le béton c'est sûr
[Musique]
en attendant les parisiens ressentent
tous plus ou moins un sentiment de
malaise qui s'est installé en e1
sensiblement pourquoi jusqu'en 1850
paris c'était développer harmonieusement
et puis à cette date les démolition
systématique du second empire ont ouvert
la voie à l'anéantissement total du
vieux paris qui se bat en s'accélérant
depuis 1950 à ménilmontant messieurs
pipart et le gris le confirme une fois
de plus je suis né pour une clinique
parce que ma mère avait les moyens de
vermette parce que les critiques mais
alors mine où tu en es pippa et 100
d'ubi 10840 cette date on croit vont les
histoires
ma grand mère par exemple qui vivent un
style une femme très peu sociable tient
vite très peu sociable déjà leurs
efforts communs commune et en rugby
montant voit un communard fuyant les
versaillais des temps dans la rue sur sa
chrysalide et cas du communard bravo ma
grand mère tout le monde se connaissait
parce que les est si populaire thesaurus
remise par les prometteurs mais c'est le
gris vous est de cet avis tout à fait
guéri
vous êtes vous-même des vinyles montano
qui pendent ménilmontant je suis même
venu du quartier disons de paris
quartier du marais alors j'ai débuté à
minuit montant et environ une quinzaine
d'années oui vous avez donc choisi
médine bontemps pas non à l'époque je
n'ai pas choisi ménilmontant j'y suis
venu par hasard
serge et j'ai trouvé j'avais quitté mon
emploi et j'ai trouvé une petite annonce
qui me demandait de venir à vivre en
famille une amende et qu'ils me
proposaient du travail avait les
montants j'ai travaillé donc chez un
employeur avait ni le montant est juste
j'ai travaillé huit ans
et lorsque je me suis mis à mon compte
j'ai tenu à rester à ménilmontant pour
la mentalité des gens mais ni de
montendre il est de l'époque
enfin il y en a encore quelle mentalité
ont-ils légende ménilmontant car ils ont
la mentalité villageoise ils ont une
mentalité tout à fait différente du
centre de paris sont point des parisiens
avant les milliers de chars ne sont pas
des parisiens
alors il vote apparaît tel qu ils
descendent à paris oui vous êtes
d'accord mais c'est bien par passer du
bon temps mais je n'ai pas normal de
l'essence
l'émergence de cas de saison qui s'en
est allé chercher chercher heureux leurs
marchandises où elle il est maintenant
paris on lit sans l'ajout zip et on vend
dans paris il ya beaucoup d'expressions
à olivet et alors les reloge en banlieue
ou en grande banlieue
quand ils sont le j en suis en vie en
règle générale sur le g6 il en va en
leur donne des loyers qui sont beaucoup
plus élevés que ce qu'ils avaient ici
des loyers qu'ils avaient ici et vous
pensez que vous allez pouvoir rester
dans le met des montants que vous avez
connu combien de temps tu espères le
plus longtemps possible mois jusqu'à ma
mort sur les chewing gum je vais vous
citer un cas j'ai une dame qui est de
ménilmontant tiéné à ménilmontant qui
doit avoir 80 ont pas loin de 90 ans il
est dans le xiiième qu'on la reloger
dans xiiie arrondissement et bien à elle
de le voyage gratuitement
elle vient faire ses courses deux fois
par semaine à ménilmontant parce qu'elle
connaît les commerçants furie elle ne
veut pas acheter dans le xiiie
arrondissement a vieilli
quand on a commencé à détruire
j'ai eu des prix vu mourir de chagrin
c'est très grave
j'ai vu le propriétaire du boulodrome
qui a été il y avait de quoi vivre
il m'a jamais dit débrouillez vraiment
important en phase en boulodrome
il est mort d'un cancer le chagrin d'un
cancer du château voilà
un cancer ne serait ce pas le mal dont
souffre paris cette multiplication
désordonnée de cellules anormales qui
lui confère une structure anarchique où
aucune régularité de disposition ni de
rapport n'existe plus qui pénètre par de
multiples effraction dans les zones
avoisinantes qui l'envahît qui le
dévoile trop souvent son ampleur que
quand il est trop tard pour la juguler
les amoureux de paris verront ils
disparaître complètement
ce qu'a fait son charme et sa réputation
des tours de notre dame à la tour
montparnasse l'ascension est
vertigineuse pour ne pas tomber de trop
haut en pastichant une ancienne chanson
on ne peut que répéter
paris prend garde
ah bon
[Musique]